the protagonist of the movie is Sean a
30 year old University Professor who has
devoted all his life to science yeah
right people who say they're doing
things for science aren't nearly this
Successful by 30 as he takes a jog
through the snowy roads he narrates that
he doesn't believe in birth after death
AKA reincarnation unfortunately as he
reaches a tunnel he suffers a cardiac
arrest and suddenly passes away at the
same time a child is born somewhere else
in the city the movie then skips forward
10 years where Sean's wife Anna is
mourning at his grave even after all
this time she has still not gotten over
his death her new boyfriend Joseph
watches over her from his car with a
hint of jealousy that evening the couple
throws a lavish house party to announce
their engagement hundreds of people are
invited and among them are Sean's
brother Clifford and his wife Clara the
two are still in contact with Anna and
love her a lot however as they are about
to enter the elevator Clara unexpectedly
excuses herself with their gift saying
she forgot to tie a ribbon around it
then she goes downstairs and sits
nervously as if she is hiding something
unbeknownst to her a young boy is
staring at her from nearby after
contemplating for a while Clara heads
outside buries the gift and then hastily
departs surprisingly the boy from
earlier has followed her and witnessed
everything the scene then cuts to Anna's
house where the party has already ended
currently her family members are
discussing the upcoming marriage just
then the boy from earlier barges inside
and says that he wants to speak with
Anna this unexpectedly startles everyone
and they inquire if he is lost the boy
simply says I am Sean I want to speak
with Anna in private slightly scared
Anna takes him into the kitchen and asks
him what he wants Sean confidently says
I want you he further reveals that he is
The Reincarnation of her husband who
died 10 years ago as expected Anna only
laughs at his claims and leads him
outside the house but even in the
elevator Sean continues being strange
with a very serious look he tells her
don't marry Joseph you are making a big
mistake this deeply upsets Anna so she
leaves him in the care of the Guard
before heading upstairs at night during
coitus she reveals about their
conversation to Joseph however he
ignores her and continues thrusting the
following day at work Anna is again
contacted by Sean this time in the form
of a letter in it he has once again
warned her against marrying Joseph Anna
shares the ladder with her family but
instead of being concerned they all
laugh it off saying it is absurd the
only one who appears to be upset is
Joseph so that night he calls the
building's guard hoping to get
information about the boy but to his
surprise Sean answers it and says that
he is waiting in the lobby for Anna
shocked Joseph rushes downstairs and
confronts the boy after a bit of
chatting he learns that Sean's parents
are in the same building so he heads to
them Anna is also called to the scene
and together the adults Force Sean to
apologize however he bluntly says no and
also explains that he will continue
pursuing Anna because she is his wife
hearing this and it becomes enraged and
warns him not to bother her again as the
couple leaves the boy suddenly collapses
to the ground Anna who lost her husband
due to a cardiac arrest is traumatized
by the sight that night before going to
bed Sean's mother approaches him to give
him words of comfort however he rudely
sends her away saying I am not your
stupid it's Sun anymore the next day as
Anna and her mother are having breakfast
together the latter reveals that Sean
had left a message on the telephone he
asked Anna to come to the tunnel hearing
this our confused protagonist becomes
even more confused as that is the exact
place where her husband died so despite
her mother's warnings she rushes to the
tunnel as soon as Sean arrives she
angrily asks why he is messing with her
in response the boy again says that he
is her husband in fact he is willing to
be interviewed by her brother-in-law Bob
who is a very good friend of the real
Sean Anna simply stares at him in shock
and disbelief in the next scene Bob
visits little Sean at his house and
conducts the interview as he turns on
the recorder he mentions that the real
Sean never believed in reincarnation he
then proceeds with the first question
where did you live the little boy
confidently says that he lived in Anna's
current apartment but he wasn't around
much due to work when Bob asks where he
worked Sean explained means that being a
lecturer he had to go to different
universities and conferences in one
instance he even lectured at Bob's
Hospital the boy continues by revealing
much more intricate details from the
real Sean's life like how he and Anna
did it on Bob's green couch several
times this conversation should be
illegal later Bob plays the recording in
front of Anna and her family shocking
everyone however for some reason Anna
has a weird smirk on her face probably
because she has started believing in the
boy's claims on the other hand Joseph
has become very concerned with the
situation he has started fearing that
anime slip away from his hands the
freaking kid's gonna bang my wife just
then the bell rings and when the
housekeeper opens the door Shawna and
his mother enter this instantly makes
the environment tense shortly after
Sean's mother has a private conversation
with Anna where she sobbingly reveals
that Sean doesn't act like her son
anymore in fact he is always rude and
angry when anyone approaches him Anna
sympathizes with the poor woman and
offers to help she requests that Sean be
allowed to stay at her place for the
night so that she can help him focus on
his studies Anna promises to pick him up
from school and return him home the next
day after a while we see Sean wandering
around the house correctly guessing all
the rooms and Furniture within he even
knows the exact place his favorite chair
is kept all the family members simply
look at him in shock and disbelief at
night while Sean is enjoying some pastry
Joseph approaches him for a private talk
he asks the boy how he remembers about
the place he died to which Sean replies
that it is all like deja vu in his mind
Joseph then asks another question where
did Shawna and Anna meet for the first
time the boy responds that they met at
the beach and instantly fell in love he
then requests to see Anna but Joseph
declines warning him to stay away from
her if you clap my wife then I'll clap
you that came out wrong in the next
scene a worried Anna goes to Sean's
brother Clifford's place and confides in
him about everything Clara is also there
and the couple listens in carefully as
Anna reveals that Sean has been
reincarnated in the form of a boy as
expected Clifford thinks that is a joke
but when Anna starts crying he realizes
that something is wrong Anna explains
that even after 10 years she has not
been able to forget Sean and now a
random boy who resembles her late
husband has come into her life Anna
doesn't want to fall in love with him
again so she pleads with Clifford to
convince the boy to go away after this
Anna picks up Sean from school and takes
him to have ice cream there she inquires
how he plans to provide for her and he
replies that he will work and it then
jokingly asks him how he will satisfy
her physical she also inquires if he has
ever made out with a girl with a serious
face the 10 year old boy says you will
be my first
oh it's Christ hearing his responses
Anna starts believing that he is
actually The Reincarnation of her late
husband so to learn a little more about
him she ditches her car and goes on a
ride with him in a carriage
unfortunately Anna misses her dinner
date with Joseph making him extremely
worried and to complicate the situation
even further she calls Sean's mother and
requests that Sean be allowed to stay
for one more night the woman misses her
son and is clearly upset about the whole
situation but nonetheless she agrees and
continues pimping out her little boy
that evening when Anna is in the bathtub
having some private time Sean weirdly
removes his clothes and joins her
shocked she asks what he's doing and the
boy replies that he is looking at his
wife and it doesn't know what to say she
simply keeps staring at Sean ultimately
Joseph finds out that they are together
so he storms away from the place angrily
he probably should have just dropped a
toaster in that thing and been done with
it that night a small musical ceremony
is held for the upcoming wedding but
Anna and Joseph can't seem to look each
other in the eye meanwhile aboard Sean
begins tapping his leg on the chair much
to the annoyance of everyone Joseph
turns around and asks the boy to stop
but when he doesn't listen Joseph
finally snaps he drags Sean across the
room and spanks him aggressively Bob and
the others managed to restrain him but
the damage has already been done the
three-way is complete a terrified Sean
runs away from the house and Anna rushes
after him Bob also goes to check on the
two and when he arrives downstairs he
shockingly sees Sean kissing Anna
disgusted he leaves without saying a
word on the other hand a furious Joseph
packs his belongings and leaves and his
mother apologizes for all the trouble
and Promises to sort things out as soon
as possible after a while Clifford
arrives at the house only to find it in
a complete mess Anna is seen weeping in
the corner and out of nowhere Sean runs
into the room and hugs Clifford the
latter observes the boy's face carefully
and concludes that he is not Sean he
says that he knows his brother well and
this one is an imposter however Anna
continues insisting the boy is her
husband reincarnated meanwhile Sean
heads out to the lobby where he is
suddenly confronted by Clara with a
smirk on her face she shows him her
dirty hands and asks him where the
bathroom is Sean nervously leads her
there and even dries her hands then
Clara writes her number on his hands
explaining that she has changed her
address for some reason this terrifies
Sean and he mumbles please don't tell
Anna that night Anna gets into an
argument with her family her mother and
sister threatened to call the cops if
she doesn't let go of the boy but Anna
is willing to take the risk she angrily
asks them to stay out of her life before
storming off following this we are taken
into a flashback to the night of the
engagement ceremony when Laura buried
the gift Sean followed her like a creep
and dug it out inside he found several
unopened letters all of them addressing
the real Sean they were sent by none
other than Anna in the present the
ten-year-old Sean visits Clara at her
place the latter immediately confronts
him for being an Empire Foster she says
that she knew right away he wasn't the
real Sean because if he was he would
have come to her first this is because
the real Sean was having an affair with
Clara he wasn't happy with Anna and
actually hated her Anna was unaware of
this and she kept sending him letters
when he was away however Sean never
opened a single one and to express his
love for Clara he gave her all of those
letters he wanted her to feel more
special Clara was also deeply in love
with him but she could never convince
him to get a divorce on the night of the
engagement she wanted to surprise Anna
with the letters but she couldn't go
through with the plan in the end little
Sean found the letters and read them all
and this is perhaps how he knows so much
about the real Sean and his wife another
theory is that he has actually become
infatuated with Anna to the point that
he has started believing that he is the
real Sean when Clara presses him to come
clean he becomes scared and runs away
from there the confrontation takes a
devastating toll on the little boy's
psyche because of which he stops seeing
Anna he spends most of his time
wandering in the wilderness and climbing
trees he even contemplates committing
the unthinkable but then stops himself
at the last moment because of his
disappearance Anna becomes restless and
falls into a state of depression however
after much consideration Sean finally
visits her one night all muddied and
dirty as he takes a bath a super excited
Anna approaches him and starts
explaining her plan she wants them to
run away and start a new life in another
city Anna says that they can get married
as soon as he reaches 21 but to her
shock the boy declines saying I am not
Sean Anna becomes anxious and asks if he
is joking but he responds I love you so
I cannot be Sean as expected this
perplexes Anna because she doesn't
understand the context however Sean
replies that he can't explain it any
better in reality he has come to terms
that he is not Sean because the real one
never loved Anna dejected that she was
played this entire time Anna gets up and
leaves the following day she heads to
Joseph's office and begs him to forgive
her and it says that she was so blinded
by her husband's arrival that she lost
control to her Delight Joseph forgives
her in an instant you're still a pedo
honey but I love you the movie then cuts
to several months later where the two
eventually do get married however Anna
is still lost in her thoughts which
Joseph notices elsewhere Sean has
started going to school regularly in a
narration he apologizes for all the mess
he created but hopes that he and Anna
can be together in another life in the
final scene Anna has a panic attack and
rushes to the beach where she first met
Sean but fortunately before she does
anything drastic Joseph stops her and
hugs her tightly he then calms her down
and takes her away from there subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching